hi everyone my name is Amy Chan today
I'm gonna talk about data science
reporting first about me I'm a data
scientist at system one it's an attack
company in Venice and there are a lot of
us today here and if you want to learn
more about the company we have a booth
outside outside of work I do a lot of
community work I am one of the
organizers for pi ladies away and I run
monthly meetups in West LA the LA our
user Meetup I also hosted the first
Saturday this year in April at UCLA
there will be another one next year so
hope to see you there so show of hands
how many here are data scientists or so
how many of you actually think about
doing reports for your data science work
do and how many of you only do it when
people ask you to do it so judging by
the title you know how much I think data
science report is important to our
day-to-day workflow and I would like to
share with you my definition about data
science work for data science reports so
I think data science reports should
inform data scientists and stakeholders
who could be your clients if you work
for a big company it could be your
product team business people people who
request for a data science solution from
you and the data science reports should
show whether a data science solution
worked how well it worked and whether it
continues to work in a long term so I'm
gonna begin with an example that's a
vending machine
so you want to build a model for this
vending machine and your task is to
recommend the bottle that lights up and
you will have of course this renovation
will be powered by a Ike and there's
some solar model behind it and us the
data scientist wants to maximize the
revenue brought by this vending machine
any questions about this before I look
at the data No okay so this is what I
usually report will look like for such a
task on the left you see a bar chart for
the revenue it's growing it's great we
are making more and more money with this
vending machine and the left you have a
table which have day-to-day reports of
the performance of this vending machine
and what's missing here any volunteer so
your many machines probably powered by a
model by AI but your reports doesn't
show in any place there's no model in
this reports and you see this every day
and a lot of tableau dashboards and you
have no idea as a model behind us and
ironically this is what people look at
every day and they judge the business
performance by these reports so my point
is do science reports are not bi data
analytics or business reports that we
see in the usual tableau dashboards it's
more than that you have to make your
model value stand out so how do you do
care data science model value land is it
less when we build model we'll look at
this kind of graphs and we call them
data science reports mostly we want to
look at the classification array we look
at the confusion matrix we look at the
training test they got
and test accuracy curve but how does
this translate to business business
people or your clients wouldn't be
interested in looking at this at all it
doesn't mean anything to them and more
importantly when you have a model in
production your data is changing every
day you can't have the same
classification read every day and it's
just too much to monitor this even for
yourself so what if we just squash data
science model accuracy with the business
report say oh we have every day the data
comes in we have passer-by which is
people who walk by our vending machine
we have below salt which is number of
bottles so by the vending machine
revenue conversion and the money made by
each passerby so these are our data but
what if you just squash accuracy as a
single column on the side it doesn't
really say anything like how well your
model really improved the vending
machine performance so tailor science
reports on that model assessment either
because even if we got 100% every day on
your model accuracy it doesn't really
mean anything to the business so this is
not too helpful so let's go back to the
good old Venn diagram data science the
people who in sees what data scientists
must have seen this kind of Venn diagram
before in my opinion data science report
should be also a Venn diagram it should
include the bi Daleks business reports
and also model assessment you have to
show both at the same time so this is my
AI of a new machine report when there is
no model we are making this much money
that's the column on the left
in a red box and when we have a model
we're actually making more money and it
shows very clearly how much your mother
is making every day and you kind of
incorporate that into the similar layout
that Business Report already are and you
can see clearly how much impact we're
bringing to the table and it's also not
too much burden for people to read this
report because it's almost the same
amount of information so any questions
so far before we begin building our
report for this vending machine I would
like to point out something that's very
important to all the data science
projects how many of you have been in a
situation where you have to argue with a
lot of other teams what kind of metric
you were optimizing in the first place
six months ago they wanted to maximize a
revenue made by the vending machine and
six months after they are interested in
something else so you did all the work
for for that for your data science model
but after six months people forgot what
we started working on and the objective
is blurred so the metric is actually the
foundation of your data science report
you have to think clearly like this is
what we're trying to optimize and this
is the cent centric Center metric that
were monitoring every day so my advice
is just to decide on just one metric
especially in business selling you don't
want to optimize two three five metric
just one and if we are focusing all our
energy on maximizing that one metric and
you have to communicate and agree on
those in events it will involve
a lot of communications and meetings and
people will have different opinions
because we have we all have different
interests in the business but
communicated this in the events would
save you a lot of time and effort so and
also it's not often but not necessary
the outcome variable of your model let
me show you how
so we have our vending machine again we
build a model that recommends drinks
which is the bottle that lights up and
we're trying to maximize money per
passerby people who walk by this man
vending machine how much do they ended
up semi on this machine and this is our
metric and let's go back to a report we
have some it would be interesting also
reporting the conversion of each of no
model and wears a size model that would
be the column in the middle the two
columns in the middle that says
conversion and we also report that no
model and data science model in the on
the right as you as you first thing and
people look at this report and start
wondering oh the conversion rate for
when there is no model is actually
greater than having data science model
why is that is the model not working and
and the original task which is to
maximize money may professor buy start
to fade it away it gets smaller and
smaller and people just look at things
they want to look at and they will tell
you all the model is not working but you
have to refocus the original objective
we are trying to maximize money made by
professor by so we focus in this
conversation is very important and
it would be helpful in a long-term so
that's why I said it's important for to
decide on one metric and kind of stick
with it in all the meetings and
follow-ups in after you launch the model
and it's often but not necessarily your
outcome variable because you could
maximize money made possible by layout
by the layout of this mending machine or
how you arrange the bottles it doesn't
have to be money professor bias your Y
variable so we can now we have a metric
to optimize on and we all agree uptown
since everything is perfect so far what
are the design components should get to
the point we have a deliverable report
every day or regularly so here are some
components that are summarized and I
think are they are not in particular
order but I think people should
especially their scientists should think
about these components before they went
on and build out their reports first is
measure of birdie which is do you have a
consistent data source and is your
report can you general report
automatically and regularly every day or
every week even annually do you have a
steady data source second is format this
is kind of how you present your data is
your table is your graph that kind of
stuff and next is channel how do you
deliver that report whether it's an
email whether it's a printed out PDF
what is it and the next one would be
something that lets people I think fewer
people will think about this how do you
utilize your report to monitor your
model health in the long term you can
actually build other
to run your report and finally think
about audience and improve your reports
in the long term let's start by
measurability can you actually regularly
and automatically build the data science
report you design an awesome report that
shows the impact of a model but if you
don't have a steady data source what's
the point
questions to answer do we have data
daily weekly monthly and that helps you
decide how frequent in sendai rapport
and data quality is it reliable data
data processing if it takes a lot of
work to process your data is that
process being automated automated what
if the answer is or terrible like you
don't have regular data sources
it comes in regularly data quality is
bad data problems processing it's not
automated then you probably shouldn't
automate this report yet and that's
again look at the our vending machine
report and show how measure ability is
very important look at this report what
sort of problem can you identify okay so
the bottles sold on November 3rd is very
suspicious you don't see only 200
bottles it's why is that is the model
not working or something's wrong in the
pipeline we don't know and on November
30 is the revenue are 0 which messed up
all your metric if you send out this
report every day regularly you could
blame like oh it's ETL teams for they'd
have engineers in good job so all my
data I messed up but why would you send
out that report in the first place it it
discredits your credibility like Oh
should I trust this any more should I be
reading this hello every day so it's
actually very important to be respond
subo and think about oh is my data
source dependable and should I automate
this report that box everybody in the
team and the next biggest question is
the format this is actually very hard
and it deserves a whole series of talk
so how do you present your data this is
a tree I just I made last night
should it be interactive if it should be
in half it should be the table apply if
it's applause Elia borrowed line chart
if it's a table should be white or wrong
it goes on and on forever it's like an
infinite deep the infinite depth tree
and even if you get to the bottom of
this mystery you used any laughs spend
another two hours just deciding on the
color so the format is very very tricky
and it takes a long time to get used to
and you would find something that works
for you but it's worth spending a time
to think about how to present your data
cleaning and in an accessible way so
there are many many tips I can give
transparency show your data performance
honestly if it's not doing well don't
try to hide it I see a lot of their
scientists because the model won't do
well every day because the data would
change every day so your mother wouldn't
be great every single day but you don't
want to hide that you want to you want
to be transparent about it with all your
stakeholders
clearly that is tray for moderate amount
of info don't put too much stuff on your
report table format the color plot avoid
too many shapes in your color which
makes people dizzy and not want to read
the report there are many many many tips
I can I can this here but the bottom
line is you yourself have to enjoy
reading the report because if yourself
don't wanna really report how would you
expect other people to get anything out
of this report and enjoy I also have
another
meaning like if the model is working you
would actually enjoy reading the report
because it shows you are bringing impact
to a table every day and another bottom
line if you want to assess whether your
data science report is working think
about if just show it to someone does
anyone who look at this report for the
first time can they make a call in five
seconds whether both business and data
science models are doing well from this
report any questions no the next design
component that I want to highlight is
the channel so I see a lot of cases
where people not just a scientist they
send our report to emails and nobody
checks an email anymore they just
totally everything or just keep them
unread for a long long time so choose
the right place to send out your report
and put your put your reporting for in
other people's face I know here's the
report just read it I did as you can see
in the first bi report business will go
on and everything will look fine even if
you don't show this report so you have
to be your own advocate you have to show
people what you did and how much the
model is actually improving the overall
operation so there are many many
channels we are these are some popular
channels a little slack is a popular one
email Google sheet dashboards and I use
are in Python and both in both cases you
can build reporting these channel for
free you don't have to spend any money
to build the report and if you have any
questions on how to use these specific
packages you can ping me afterwards I'm
not gonna demo the code here an event
text message just do whatever works get
to the people who actually should care
Yamato so next is next component is
alerts this is something I don't see a
lot of people do a lot of data science
work is done and model performance is
great and you build a rapport
it kind of just regularly updates and
over time people might not be interested
in reading it anymore and you can make a
report work for you like if we are
monitoring the data science lives on
this meant vending machine every day
this number better be positive if it's
not we have to investigate why and you
can easily build a if statement report
and if Simon Alert and pin you about we
our numbers in this report and this is
something we can easily do and it's very
easy for anyone to to bring up to notice
there is a problem
so next component let's go back to a
fundamental who are you trying to talk
to the audience is your stakeholder who
the people who uses your model and also
yourself how would you benefit yourself
in six in six months by reading this
report me myself I build a lot of models
that work in production and sometimes I
forget about them and three months later
somebody asked me to check one model I
can just pull out my report and I see oh
maybe something's wrong and I can easily
identify what the problem is and start
writing a sequel etc to check the data
so you're building this report for
yourself so you want yourself to be you
want it to be a pleasant experience to
read your report in six months
so use the report to measure and monitor
data science performance and another
thing that I accidentally bet have found
the reports are I discover a lot of
missed opportunities in the reports
because
when you list all the data every day you
can see pattern you see optimization
opportunity for example we look at the
case where conversion rate was greater
when there is no model why is that we
could do more work on that and your data
science report would help you discover
those opportunities and in a long term
it's just healthier to maintain that
relationship with all the clients inside
the organization you have to educate
your audience on data science philosophy
like if you if you have your audience
read the report every day they will get
used to it and start asking questions
around the numbers they see in any
report so I'm gonna showcase some some
stuff I can make I use are and this is a
slack message it's clean it's a weekly
report on the vending machine and it it
sent out to a public channels or anyone
who have anything to do with the vending
machine project and look at this report
and ask me questions so transparency is
achieved and I think the report is
pretty clear like how well it's doing
and it doesn't have all the confusing
data science metrics that we monitor
because we can keep that to ourselves
and Google she is also a popular choice
the nice thing about Google sheets you
can even import back to your RO Python
and then analyze the performance data in
the long term so saying all that I just
want all the data scientists to go back
home and check your data science reports
if you have any make just ask yourself
these questions whether your DSN report
show if the model works how well worth
and whether your continuous work does
they have the ability to help you
monitor a model in a long
and just be responsible for things you
pull out a production the main takeaway
if you didn't get anything out of it
it's too much information I think people
should to really go home and see that
starts think about how data analyst
report should be a part of your data
science work for so design report before
anything anyone asks for it it will
benefit yourself tremendously because
when people ask you a question about
your model you could answer it right
away and people will be amazed whoa how
did you think of that beforehand because
you made a report just read it and tell
them the answer right there and you also
benefit your future self because you
never know how long your mother was
gonna run some model runs for three
years I have my local that runs for two
years I never looked at it some some
days a guy paint me and asked me to
check the model and I can just pull out
the report it's very easy and I have
some back house flies if there's no
questions hi there so a lot of what I'm
seeing with your reports is you're
comparing with and without a model I'm
assuming that that has the assumption
that some subset of devices are not
running the model what do you do in
situations where you you know business
reasons or whatnot you everything is
even formally applied do you have any
recommendations for that it's it's
actually part of why I said it's part of
our report will help you build up the
data science philosophy because
sometimes you need to ask your
cooperating teams that all we need to
have a continuous baseline to monitor so
that we have something to compare to and
it takes a while people to accept that
because they are like oh if they had we
have an awesome model why don't we apply
it on everything and everything and it
takes time to advocate that but the
reporting apps also help you do that
because when you
Shola you can tell them oh it's very
clear that it's working or not and we
can do this for years and years and yeah
it's just very straightforward for
people to our monitor in the long term
whereas you have one solution working on
all the vending machines you wouldn't
have to have Burleigh yeah how do you
sort of maintain interest in a report
especially if things are going really
well for weeks or months on end and
things are looking good I mean I'm
assuming people are eventually just kind
of like I'm sure it's fine no it's not
that's how the allure part would help so
if you build alert also before anyone
asks for it
you build alert and for myself I have
like 10 reports I don't look at them
every day and if something's wrong it
will ask me to check it so that's why
it's also very important to define like
important metrics you wanna monitor so
you can pin yourself you can't possibly
look at all the data every day yeah so I
think I have time for my backup slides
so I'm gonna make some out for my
coworker he's gonna present on embed
using embedding layers to manage high
cardinality tomorrows and I encourage
you to check out that talk it's very
very different from mine and I have
another batch of slides a note on tiny
data how many of you are familiar with
the Teddy data principle it's proposed I
think by Hallie Wickham and yeah so one
one one problem I couldn't get around
myself is I'm used to seeing only tidy
data like only tiny did that make sense
to me like it just looks weird when you
hide a variable value inside column
names but in my for my experience
readability is more important like how
to present your data in a readable way
instead of in a tidy way
you're not using the data to press to
processing to do any data analysis so
it's more important to have it in a
readable format and for those who
they're not familiar with paddy data
here's the code and you can just read
that so in my experience even though in
some cases where the business
stakeholders and the data science team
and the overall engineering team come to
a decision is still like the one metric
that you decide to measure sometimes
after the fact as you would mentioned
you know maybe some months will pass by
and suddenly to the business
stakeholders something else is of
importance so in those cases even though
maybe you've already addressed what that
one metric is from the get like how do
you adapt and like how have you
personally encountered those situations
and navigated those conversations if you
because it's a if it's a different
metric that's not what you were building
the model for in the first place so you
either have to persuade other people
that we have to stick with the metric
and only if you think it still makes
sense but if the metrics is changing and
we need to realign the goal then we
should rethink about the whole project
and probably build a new report on IVA
model to adjust the situation yeah I
guess there are no more questions thanks
Amy it was a very informative
[Applause]